bonsoir Le 7 8 l'actu sur téléfilm 78
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale en
direct des 18h chaque soir répondez
cette semaine nous partons pour la
verrière la verrière qui devrait dès le
printemps voir fleurir à 14 caméras de
vidéoprotection interpellée par
l'insécurité au niveau des centres
commerciaux la municipalité communiste a
décidé de mettre en place plusieurs
mesures dont celle-ci on rappelle que
les chiffres de la délinquance en
français dans les Yvelines ne sont pas
bons pour 2013 Yolaine Torres
les centres commerciaux de la verrière
bientôt sous vidéo protection avant
l'été prochain 14 caméras seront
réparties sur les commerces de la ville
interpellé sur les conditions de vie et
de tranquillité dans ces quartiers la
municipalité a entamé un travail avec
les commerçants la police ou encore les
riverains pour lutter contre
l'insécurité cette vidéoprotection n'est
qu'un complément parmi d'autres mesures
personne ne se fait l'illusion c'est pas
la pause de la vidéoprotection qui règle
les problèmes d'insécurité c'est la
vidéoprotection plus le travail de
police plus le travail de prévention
plus le travail de médiation peut se
travailler d'animation c'est cet
ensemble qui aide à traiter
ce qu'il souhaite traiter c'est
notamment le problème des trafics mais
aussi les phénomènes de bande et de
regroupement des enjeux que le maire
tente d'aborder aussi par une médiation
et un meilleur accompagnement des jeunes
pour les riverains ces caméras semblent
plutôt bien accueillies en Hospital à la
pharmacie ni à la poste avec tous ces
individus qui traînent là franchement
c'est une très bonne idée je pense que
ce sera attendu à la vie privée des gens
et ça peut être utile pour la police
quoi
c'est tout ça va être super
on va se sentir en sécurité tout ça
les travaux démarreront au printemps et
devraient être terminés avant l'été au
total cette mesure coûtera plus de
200000 euros à la commune dont une
partie financée par l'État
sociale à présent le mouvement de
protestation des salariés de SKF France
leader mondial dans le domaine du
roulement mécanique qui continue sur le
site de Montigny-le-Bretonneux une
trentaine de personnes en grève à
bloquer symboliquement les accès pour
les voitures en cause le PSE le plan de
sauvegarde de l'entreprise qui prévoit
une restructure 51 salariés de Montigny
doivent être transférés sur un autre
site à Saint-Cyr-sur-Loire près de Tours
la direction a prévu un plan
d'accompagnement pour les salariés
concernés mais les syndicats CGT et CFE
CGC s'inquiète pour les personnes qui ne
pourraient ou ne voudraient pas
déménager ils ont assigné SKF en justice
décision attendue le 13 février à la
direction tente de son côté de faire
voter un accord majoritaire le comité
central d'entreprise doit donner son
avis demain mardi
depuis le 20 aucune condition
significative nous a permis d'arrêter le
la bagarre puisque notre direction fait
la sourde oreille
ne répond pas aux interrogations posées
par le personnel à savoir qu'elle est ce
motif de transfert quel est le motif
économique pourquoi des significatives
existent Saint-Cyr-sur-Loire et pas pour
le personnel de Montigny
tout ça nous avons pas de réponse la
situation financière d'escale
en complètement scène
une moyenne de 50 à 70 millions sont
distribués régulièrement tous les ans
aux actionnaires le PSE devrait être à
la hauteur des résultats d'escaf ce
n'est pas le cas invité de cette
première édition du 7 8 7 de la semaine
Nicolas Hardy bonsoir président de
l'association des parents d'élèves
indépendants de trap et Michael tan
bonsoir à vous le membre de la scped
Yvelines avec vous nous allons parler de
ces rumeurs qui persistent malgré la
multiplication et des démenti officiels
théories du genre éducation sexuelle
serait prévu dès la rentrée 2014 en
maternelle c'est en tout cas ce que
laisse croire des SMS envoyés par un
collectif jour de retrait de l'école
essayer de leur donner un maximum
d'informations entre autres les renvoyer
vers les sources officielles qui
montrent bien que on est bien loin de ce
qui est ce qui est le changement ne vont
pas arriver derrière en tout cas on va
passer ce genre de choses alors ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que la BCD de
l'égalité n'est pas mise en place ici
actuellement alors voir situer les
choses la BCD de l'égalité que vous
mentionnez justement c'est un petit peu
le point de départ de toute ces rumeurs
en tout cas cette vague de de rumeur qui
est né ensuite sur sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est une mesure pour l'égalité
homme-femme qui commence à être mis en
place dans une dizaine de départements
tests et dans cet ABCD de l'égalité on
trouve ce genre de choses qu'est-ce
qu'on trouve dans ce dans cette dans ces
textes donc justement en fait
le gouvernement a mis sur en ligne
justement un document en fait peut-être
que vous avez ou directement mais qui
est disponible en ligne qui permet en
fait de répondre à un certain nombre de
points qui étaient clairement cité dans
dans
on pourrait les appeler des pourriels en
fait
puisqu'ils se base sur rien de construit
alors pour un peu pour aller plus loin
dans les rumeurs ces rumeurs sont partis
de plusieurs rapports notamment un
rapport de l'OMS européen qui
commençaient qui évoquait effectivement
la théorie du genre sauf que ce rapport
n'est toujours pas arrivé en France
puisqu'il a été traduit en allemand puis
en français mais en Suisse théorie des
gens assez négation de la
différenciation sexuelle parce qu'on en
parle beaucoup et on explique assez peu
ce que c'est on a également le rapport
déchaîné qui a été remis au ministre le
au mois de juin 2013 donc effectivement
mais en avant le la BCD de l'égalité
et en fin de compte de ces rapports des
des extraits ont été retirés de ces de
ces rapports en les retirant de leur
contexte voilà donc effectivement le but
est aujourd'hui c'est de rassurer ce
qu'on fait depuis pratiquement deux
semaines de rassurer les parents et
effectivement de leur dire que l'égalité
l'ABC de l'égalité c'est promouvoir dès
le plus jeune âge l'égalité sur le plan
sociétal
du garçon et de la fille et de l'homme
et de l'homme et de la femme veut dire
qu'en maternelle ça se travaille depuis
déjà enfin sur strap ça travaille depuis
des années ou en maternelle on les
petits garçons ils jouent également avec
des yeux de fille ça va la chose
avant avant même que ces textes existent
tout à fait il y avait plusieurs points
très précis qu'on a pu entendre dans les
rumeurs qui ont été véhiculées sur les
réseaux sociaux ou par les SMS éducation
sexuelle dès la maternelle qu'il y a des
intervenants homosexuels aussi dans les
classes il n'est pas question de tout ça
dans les textes de l'ABC c'est de la
pure invention ou virer
très des contextes des textes
on sort des éléments de leur contexte et
après effectivement on amplifie les on
amplifie les les éléments ou les rumeurs
donc non non il y aura il n'y aura pas
la seule
mon collègue de FC peut disait
effectivement le seul le seul projet qui
est mis en place dans 10 académies
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement la BCD
de l'égalité promouvoir l'égalité garçon
fille on n'est pas sur le secteur des
Yvelines ce texte n'est pas en
application actuellement c'est vrai que
en fait je pense que la confusion vient
chez certains parents parce qu'on parle
de sexuel mais sexuel c'est la façon le
sexe du garçon féminin pour la fille et
donc effectivement je pense que c'est
aussi sur ce type de de de
choses que en fait ce bas ces rumeurs
alors qu'effectivement
nous on travaille avec le plan local de
santé en fait avec l'hôpital et puis des
des
infirmières scolaires etc l'éducation
nationale et il est clair que
l'ensemble des acteurs
procèdent avec avec beaucoup de
délicatesse pour aborder des thèmes que
les enfants vont être amenés à
rencontrer dans leur vie que ce soit au
niveau des élémentaires mais aussi au
niveau de du collège par la suite où là
c'est mis en
pratique entre guillemets si on dépasse
un peu juste le cadre quand même des
rumeurs ces rumeurs qui sont nées et qui
finalement vous me l'avez dit sont
fondées sur des déjà de la fabulation et
puis aussi certains textes ce texte
programme de l'ABCD de l'égalité qui a
été lancé par le ministère des Droits
des Femmes et de l'éducation nationale
également pour bien resituer le contexte
là c'est en phase de test dans une
dizaine d'académies est-ce que c'est une
bonne chose déjà au-delà des rumeurs ne
serait-ce que l'idée de promouvoir
l'égalité des sexes la différenciation
l'égalité et bien sûr c'est c'est une
bonne chose il faut continuer
l'Académie de Montpellier qui a
travaillé sur dessus depuis quelques
années donc le rapport c'est fille et
garçon sur le chemin de l'égalité donc
de l'école à l'université ce rapport des
montres déjà l'inégalité dans la
scolarité des garçons et des filles
selon à selon après que ça soit
technique ou au niveau lycée que ce soit
technique ou général et tous tout ça il
faut le reprendre et le reprendre à la
source et dire dès le plus jeune âge
mais dire que un métier n'est pas
réservé aux garçons ou aux filles alors
que les enseignants luttent contre les
stéréotypes sexistes c'est une bonne
chose ça fait partie des missions en
tant que parents d'élèves vous êtes
content que les enseignants abordent ce
genre de questions
après attention comment on le fait bien
sûr bon toute façon effectivement les
représentants parents d'élèves sont là
justement pour pour
modérer ce qui pourrait être excessif et
on n'hésite pas à le faire en règle
générale
attention à comment on le fait
c'est-à-dire à mon avis je ne sais pas
si euh
si on a réellement
le l'intérêt à parler de des excès alors
que en fait c'est plutôt le travail qui
est fait en faveur de l'égalité qui est
bien entendu on peut on peut aller au
marge et de ce qui pourrait être fait
mais ça en parlons plutôt de ce qui est
fait donc la promotion de l'égalité
c'est et c'est pas fait que chez nous et
c'est pas fait quand que que pour
préserver les filles c'est aussi pour
préserver les garçons c'est fait au
Canada s'est fait en Suède et entre
autres parfois on est étonné de voir que
certains rapports on arrive à indiquer
qu'il faut faire une attention
particulière
aux garçons dans certains domaines parce
qu'ils ont des difficultés que les
filles n'ont pas et les amener à à les
corriger justement pour avoir l'égalité
en tout cas c'est vraiment le mérite de
faire naître tout un débat sur ces
questions là et d'intéresser les parents
à ses évolutions de programme et à
mettre en lumière l'ABCD de l'égalité
donc finalement on parlait peu dans le
reste de la France à part les académies
qui étaient directement concernés pour
la phase de test aujourd'hui pour pour
conclure vous leur dites quoi aux
parents d'élèves qui viennent vous voir
vous leur dites ne vous inquiétez pas
continuer à amener vos enfants à l'école
parce que derrière ces rumeurs il y
avait aussi ce message de ne pas emmener
les enfants à l'école pour contester et
marquer symboliquement la désapprobation
surtout qu'on a travaillé de la même
manière au niveau national au niveau
national un communiqué aussi a été fait
rappelant un petit peu
rappelant toutes ces choses bon déjà une
une des principes de Lina c'est que la
primauté de l'éducation revient aux
parents et reste aux parents
effectivement il y a c'est ses parents
de d'éduquer leurs parents leurs enfants
par contre oui non aux parents aux
enfants non aux parents aux parents
d'élèves plutôt oui ben qu'il soit rassu
la théorie du genre ne rentrera pas dans
l'école le ministre l'a dit le président
l'a dit le Premier ministre on l'a dit
il y a pas d'inquiétude de ce côté voilà
et les les
inspecteurs d'académie nous le disent
aussi d'accord voilà et en fait on peut
tout à fait comprendre que certains
parents puissent avoir des inquiétudes
enfin en tout cas des questionnements
vis-à-vis de l'école par contre
retirer son enfant n'est pas autorisé
déjà pour commencer et s'ils ont un
questionnement vis-à-vis de l'école
plutôt que de le retirer et
frémites des questions
d'aller à la source
un petit peu le le constat ou le
reproche qu'on peut faire effectivement
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas eu les parents
n'ont pas eu le réflexe de d'aller
surtout apeuré par ses SMS bon on l'a
bien compris le mieux c'est encore de
venir à la source pour avoir
l'information merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau nous en dire déjà un un petit
peu plus ce soir elle était l'invité du
7 8 l'actu jeudi dernier son interview
est d'ailleurs à revoir en replay sur
notre site internet Valérie Pécresse est
aujourd'hui prise à partie par le
collectif de la manif pour tous il lui
reproche son vote positif à l'Assemblée
concernant le texte de loi égalité homme
femme alors qu'elle avait pris la parole
en tête du cortège lors de la
mobilisation pour la famille à
Versailles le 15 décembre dernier à la
manif pour tous dit déplorer ce
revirement et le condamné Valérie
Pécresse qui tiendra par ailleurs ce
soir un nouveau rendez-vous dans le
cadre de ses débats de Versailles à
l'université un terrage le principe une
invitation autour d'un livre ce soir
François de closet journaliste écrivain
pour maintenant ou jamais
ce week-end le vélo de ROM a été au
coeur de l'actualité nationale avec ce
record époustouflant sur la piste de
Robert Marchand 102 ans reportage à
découvrir d'ailleurs ce soir dans notre
prochaine édition du 7 8 sport avec
Anthony reesch le public a aussi
découvert ce tout nouveau complexe à
travers des journées porteuses ouvertes
retour sur l'événement du weekend
sur le parvis les files d'attente sont
de plus en plus longues pendant deux
jours le vélo Drôme de 50 ans en
Yvelines a ouvert ses portes au grand
public et un seul mot vient à la bouche
des visiteurs dirait que c'est très très
impressionnant toute la voûte qui a
au-dessus avec tous les espèces de rail
je sais pas ce que c'est mais c'est une
construction qui est très
impressionnante oui
à peine entrer dans l'enceinte les
curieux aperçoivent la pistolympique et
la plupart s'attardent à contempler cet
outil unique au monde en tribune c'est
très aéré vraiment je pense qu'on a un
point de vue magnifique sur la piste et
l'air centrale n'importe où on se trouve
dans le dans l'installation donc c'est
très très bien la réalisation
des gradins au centre de la piste il ne
fallait descendre que quelques marches
pour se retrouver exceptionnellement sur
la centrale zone habituelle de
l'échauffement des professionnels
l'occasion d'approcher l'équipement
spécifique nécessaire pour la piste on
en a un mais pour la route il y a des
freins il y a tout ça celui-là il est un
peu plus léger
il y a le minimum strict minimum il fait
quand même ça doit pas ça doit pas te
donner ça
très beau ça fait envie d'en faire
si cette opération permet de faire
découvrir le Centre national du cyclisme
elle pourrait faire naître quelques
vocations la piste est une discipline
assez méconnue parce qu'il y a très peu
de vélos de Drôme encore moins de se
calibre là puisque on peut considérer
que le site est vraiment unique donc
voilà c'est forcément quelque chose
qu'il faut démocratiser et puis qu'il
faut expliquer aux gens du territoire
qui sont pas tous des cyclistes voilà
ce weekend 12000 personnes ont pu
découvrir le vélo drone
en marge de ces portes ouvertes au
Vélodrome ce week-end certains ont
manifesté pour réclamer d'autres pistes
cyclables c'est le cas du collectif de
réappropriation de l'espace public et de
l'association Vélodrome ils étaient
présents samedi midi pour inauguré une
non piste cyclable à Trappes
l'association dénonce le financement du
vélo drone alors que d'après ses membres
il manque des équipements sur
l'agglomération vélo de RAM revendique
une quarantaine d'adhérents la
communauté d'agglomération le
département la région investissent
énormément d'argent dans un vélo Drôme
qui pour nous est un équipement qui sera
pas nécessairement très utile au 50
chinois et par contre cet argent ne va
pas à l'aménagement des points durs de
des pistes cyclables de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc il y a
certains points qui sont repérés depuis
des années depuis des schémas directeurs
de 2008 qui sont repérés comme des
points durs des points dangereux pour
les cyclistes et depuis des années nous
n'avons pas les aménagements nécessaires
au quotidien des 50 chinois alors que
nous allons avoir un vélo de route
fin du journal pour ce lundi merci de
nous avoir suivis rendez-vous demain 18h
pour un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité locale le journal vous sera
présenté par Catherine zolato bonne
soirée